premier ministre qui prose qui propose
la fusion des deux départements
la création de la région grand est
semble-t-il convaincu quelques réticents
y compris dans le haut rhin dont
brigitte klinkert est la présidente
c'est une étape décisive pour la
renaissance institutionnel et politique
de l'alsace le rapport marx parle bien
de compétences transférées de l'état à
la collectivité d'alsace il parle du
bilinguisme de la gestion du rhin de la
gestion des transports
aujourd'hui l'axé nord-sud routier
alsacien est complètement encombré
si demain la collectivité d'alsace
dispose de la compétence sur les routes
nationales nous pourrons mettre en place
par exemple une redevance pour les poids
lourds sur cet axe et ainsi rendre la
circulation plus fluide dans le domaine
de l'apprentissage des langues
aussi il est important que demain tous
les jeunes alsaciens soit au moins
bilingues voire trilingues
le sondage paru au mois de février
dernier indiquait bien que 83% des
alsaciens souhaite une collectivité
d'alsace interview réalisée par le
correspondant de rtl en alsace
yannick olland